to anyone out there bitching about Tom
Cruise's height in this movie here's a
newsflash for you Tom Cruise since the
beginning of time has always been like
two inches taller than Peter Dinklage
that's just the reality of the situation
any Tom Cruise action movie anywhere in
reality would actually be like hey men
I'm gonna kick your ass
reality for you
jack reacher so Jack preacher was
marketed as some kickass Jason Statham
movie starring Tom Cruise it's actually
not like that it's actually a murder
investigation movie starring Jack
Reacher played by Tom Cruise he was as
military MP guy who has a really keen
eye for investigation and that's not
really a bad thing me saying the movie
has more substance than was advertised
isn't bad for the movie now this movie's
a mixed bag I feel like people are going
to be like it was so awesome and other
people are gonna be like it just wasn't
that awesome
first of all Tom Cruise is Jack Reacher
I thought he was really good in the
movie he doesn't always kick ass in the
movie although there are a couple of
scenes where he completely does kick ass
but he pulls it off in a way where it's
like all right if he's not kicking the
out of someone you know he
completely could there are three action
sequences in this movie that I thought
were completely kick-ass they are the
three action sequences that are actually
in this movie two of which are in the
trailer one where he kicks the out
of the punks in the bar the other one
where this is big car chase sequence
through the city I thought that was
awesome and at the end of the movie
where he's you know doing his end of the
movie action sequence that was cool to
the rest of the movie is him
investigating this murder main murder
being this guy when all DC sniper and
killed five people so he's like oh did
he do that why did he do that time for
me to get all Alex Cross on you now the
fact that the movie is some murder
investigation movie I should like that
more than I did but the execution makes
me pull back and go it's not as good as
it should be just because I've seen
better investigations on TV shows and
other movies and because the movie has
some comedic timing where you're like
comedic yes timing wasn't that great
example there's this one scene where
these two guys one guy has a crowbar the
other has a baseball bat they're
swinging at Tom Cruise and they're
missing one will hit the wall the other
will swing past Tom Cruise hit the other
guy the other guy all rev up hit the
other guy the other guy will swing it's
they were hitting each other the only
thing that was missing from that scene
was the Benny Hill song and a bunch of
fast-forward the only thing that was
missing the problem was something like
that is it makes you analyze the rest of
the comedic moments in the movie I now
know that there's a cartoon hidden in
this movie there are times in this movie
where you step back and you're like it's
like this movie's a Tom Cruise show at a
point in this movie I thought to myself
I was like if Tom Cruise wasn't the main
guy would I give any sort of about
this movie the answer's no I just vision
someone like Arnie hammer being Jack
Reacher and I was like I would probably
just not care the movie would premiere
on Netflix that's the only thing you
would ever see about it now so
I'm on this movie big-time but
the movie did have enjoyable aspects
like I mentioned cool action scenes Tom
Cruise was a badass it was cool seeing
him investigate movie had some brains
and brawn but how it was all mix didn't
work this movie is like hamburger mint
and oranges if you're the Next Iron Chef
or something you can take those three
ingredients and make one platter that's
probably really good what this director
did was put it all in a blender and hit
frappe and serve it to us it didn't
really mix how it should happen it
leaves you going well that wasn't really
what I wanted out of the movie I want to
just give this movie a good time no
alcohol required but that implies a good
time no alcohol required at any price
and I would say matinee so I've got to
bust it back to Jack Reacher is a really
good time if you're drunk ya know it's a
party this movie's on cruise control
that's what this movie should have been
called Tom Cruise in cruise control so
your favorite Tom Cruise movie we're
talking of all time here but not Top Gun
that's cheating you can't say Top Gun if
it's Top Gun alright what's your second
favorite whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more